today we continue our discussion on the
future of the Common Agricultural Policy
we address the key elements direct
payments environmental and climate
action and role development we agreed
that in the future
direct payments should be made simple
and should be provided to active farmers
The ministers agreed that we showed my
good use of CIP and be more ambitious
about the environment we need to
continue working for job growth in the
rural areas so people have reasons to
stay and work here I think we all share
the Polish view that we need a range of
instruments to support rural development
and they to develop more synergies
between different EU policies and of
course cohesion policy as well
the Commission's communication and the
MFF which was published last week though
served as something of a backdrop to the
today's discussions it's an important
contribution to those discussions it set
out various options scenarios it wasn't
a proposal but of course I did note that
there was no reference to pillar 1
co-financing in that particular document
and the Bioeconomy which I believe is
enormous potential for jobs and wrote in
the rural areas but particularly it has
an enormous potential for additional
income for our farmers if they wish to
invest in this particular economy in the
future